something your teachers don't want you
to know with online school if you
really don't feel like typing notes just
press your fn key twice
this will literally type what your
teacher is saying and you won't have to
write notes
instead of google use google scholar
because once you do this you can
literally press these buttons and it
cites everything for you and they have
more precise articles
they're called email trackers i can tell
my teachers have opened my emails and
how many times and if they have it
so when they say this you'll know you'll
just know
go to the google app and press the
camera icon they have a homework section
underneath
and your homework with this and it'll
literally tell you the right answer
it's called the youtube transcript this
basically shows you
everything that's being said in the
video and you can press ctrl
f if you're ever given a worksheet just
press the keywords that you're looking
for and they'll come up here and you
won't have to watch the whole video
[Music]
a lot of teachers upload their lessons
from zoom
to the cloud converter and it gives us
audio transcript
hypothetically you could copy paste all
of the transcripts put them into one
document and then when you're doing open
book exams
you press control f and search keywords
so you'd practically get every question
right
don't have to read your articles guy
instead use podcastle free chrome
extension convert your articles into
podcasts
make a shared document like a google doc
that's a study guide for midterm
and finals now share this document with
everyone in your class
and get everyone to add stuff in now you
can learn off other people's things
and they can learn off yours if you
forget to hand an assignment on your
past a time
go to your time and date settings and
change them the portal will reset
and you actually won't be late instead
of google use google scholar
this will help you find more reliable
sources and it's easier to navigate
especially for research projects you
don't know how to start off your essay
do it with
a quote and then also explain the quote
this adds more words to your essay and
it
acts as a hook to engage your reader if
you're allowed to pick your own essay
talker
choose one that makes you angry this
will allow you to run
on and on about your topic and you won't
be worried about being short of the word
limit once you're done writing your
essay
copy and paste it onto a word to text
reader this will read out your essay and
allow you to catch your mistakes when
you're doing research on your essay
topic
put ppt after your research topic this
will bring up powerpoints which have
important and concise information about
your research topic that will help you
understand what to include in your essay
and whatnot
do you suck at math well here's a tool
to help you with that it's called math
chops
it's a math prep tool that has a
database of the most common
sat and act questions they use an
algorithm to check where you're bad at
and help you with that
form of games which is so fun
you